they're probably asking yourself why i'm
dangling off a rope a thousand feet off
the ground
i'm asking the same question well disney
wanted to make a show about longevity
turns out this has something to do with
it
here we go
[Music]
i'm getting older now
i don't feel invincible
it makes me want to push myself to such
an extreme and live as long as i can
and continue to make the most of every
moment
if you push yourself beyond the point at
which you should be coming out there is
a real risk you could die why am i doing
this why am i doing this
[Music]
what's making you nervous oh death is
usually a big one yeah
we want to make you so resilient how can
we be present with our stress now so
that it doesn't kill us later so strong
so powerful if this is gonna challenge
your body it'll challenge your brain too
that you can go toe-to-toe with father
time and he's not even gonna bog you
we'd change your body to do a reboot on
your system you know we're basically
going to need sort of chris hemsworth
2.0 the new
[Music]
[Applause]
me let's get on with it shall we
[Music]